[Music]
this is a man who accepted his
invitation to the International back
here on the richness ensuring advance of
this Saturday night in Staples Center
the latest iteration of Showtime
championship boxing which Al Bernstein's
been part of since 2003 good to see al
it's good to be here
I was actually outraged it took them a
few extra years I was thinking of
staying home then I said no I think I'll
go right then you saw the people that
were and I said maybe it's okay good to
see you yeah it's good to be here very
nice to visit again before we get to all
the sweet science you sir can speak to
the level of excitement in Las Vegas
Nevada of what a Vegas Golden Knights
have been pulling off you've been to
some of those once again seven the
playoff games cuz I've been traveling so
much yes but I did attend the number of
games during this season and the way it
has gripped the city is extraordinary
honest you know Las Vegas is you know a
city where there's been a lot of
transients but in recent years we had
more and more people who've been there
for a long time I've been there for
almost 25 or 30 years and there are two
things in that city that changed the
city one was we got a fine art center
called the Smith Center which is
extraordinary and if five years ago and
that's been a real focal point and then
the hockey team came the Golden Knights
and it has galvanized the city in a way
that is remarkable might have done it
even if they'd just been moderately
successful but because they've done so
well it's just been an overriding force
that I mean it's really been an
incredible story that's what I'm saying
like win or lose tonight or in whatever
games that have the if necessary
asterisk on right now this is a sports
story that has not been ever seen I
don't seem like I know there have been
you know when you go back and look at
the annals of expansion teams some have
done fairly well but I don't really
remember anything like this and and it's
been extraordinary and you know the
other thing is the organization and the
team and they've done it the right way
you know it's been a very well oiled
machine
now obviously the sport that you are
closely associated with
we've seen underdog mama sure but that
just takes want one punch that's
actually Froman exactly this has been
months months long you have to I mean
they've been consistently good
throughout the season and then most
people thought they would lose to the
Winnipeg Jets when they played them the
Jets were considered maybe the best team
and it's ironic that after they beat the
Jets they thought maybe they'd most
people thought they might have beaten
the best team but the Cape's who you
know God knows whoever wins this series
you can't begrudge the caps for finally
winning a Stanley Cup
speaking of beating the Jets the Raiders
are coming to town yes so you've got
that coming off to time in Las Vegas and
it's it there are so many sports fans
there most people come to Las Vegas of
course they know about the strip and
they know about the gambling but it's
become a pretty large and sports centric
community al Bernstein here on the Rich
Eisen show what in the heck is going on
with triple G right now can you blame
this out for every well I don't think my
own opinion and I'm not intricately
involved with it but from the people
I've talked to I think he is backing off
the 50/50 you know he was distressed
obviously that they lost they both lost
he lost a lot of money and the fight
went away because of the testing with
Canelo and so they funneled that into
being a more hardline negotiators in
terms of the money they wanted a 50/50
split Canelo didn't want to do that he
brings probably the bulk of the the
fandom to it and when Oscar De La Hoya
and publicly announced we're moving on
the Ivan Alba told the triple G is
backed off as 50/50
and discretion is better part of valor
and now I think they're renegotiating
the question is whether they'll get it
done did you know they had another you
know another option in terms of Danny
Jacobs who was a very fine fighter and
they were gonna negotiate with that he
heard for him so my guess would be it's
like a 50/50 proposition whether it's
Canelo and triple G I think there's at
least a 50% chance he'll still make that
deal middle of September you think we're
it would be he's gonna fight can always
gonna find out September 15th no matter
what so it just depends on well I mean
everybody wants to see this fight
absolutely and and and you know we're in
an era in boxing where these last
several years more often fights are
getting made than not getting made you
know often that hasn't always been the
case in boxing obviously but in this
climate big fights and good fights are
more often made like Anthony Joshua and
Deontay Wilder good chance that will be
made later this year and if it isn't
made later this year will be made early
next year um you know the sport has done
a much better job of that okay now
Bernstein here on the Rich Eisen show
who's fighting Saturday for those night
we have a very good fight out here and
it'll be the Staples Center will be
pretty much packed with people
Abner Mara's and Leo Santa Cruz they
fought in 2015 had one of the best
fights of the year a majority decision
for Leo Santa Cruz and it should be an
extraordinary fight there's an
all-action fight the first time no
reason to expect it to be less we had
your boy Mauro here yeah
what an incredible documentary that is
great documentary and he you know what
what has it been like for you to sit
next to him and see what struggles he
might go through off air and then as he
said you know with Mauro Ranallo using
the on-air hmm as therapy yes
in a way what has it been from sitting
next to him good question and as you are
what they do on occasion to ask
excellent question for you to say this
to me yes but it really is interesting
because sitting with him and seeing him
you know over the last what five or six
years since I've been doing the boxing
with it maybe more you can they
have been moments I'm gonna be he was
honest in his essay in his documentary
and I'll be honest well I can feel the
angst you know I'm sitting right next to
him and I I can feel the angst and I can
feel him working through it and trying
to to make the what he does on that
broadcast the thing that brings him out
of difficult moments I think he'd be the
first to tell you that you know there's
doing live television especially live
remote television of events it can be a
stressful thing and it's ironic that
that's the thing that he's used as his
way of getting away from other problems
so there have been moments where I felt
kind of helpless because I didn't know
what to do to make everything okay but
he's always performed as it is a true
professional and he's always found his
way past it and and and and and I love
Morrow you know he's a lovely man and at
the end of the day that's the part that
you that's the reason people would
friend well in this documentary as well
that people should check out on Showtime
sports that was that air just a couple
weeks ago as part of Mental Health
Awareness Month and mates it really was
raw and wasn't coming here he was it was
great to have him here it's pretty neat
that he enjoyed being here he mentioned
it to me and he really did and and and I
think it's a story that for people to
hear it is important to hear because so
many people sometimes have probably a
little bit you know they're not as
anxious to reach out for help as maybe
they should be al Bernstein here a
couple more minutes without here on the
rich odds and show 15 years with Joe
Tom's yeah boxing what give me give me
the highlight what do you got it's been
a great time you know for me coming from
ESPN where I you know I had a great run
but where I didn't get to do always the
major fights you know I did a lot of
pay-per-view fights so I was lucky to to
be involved in those without a second
you and I did I did yes hold a field
more or two that's right that felt
pretty big well no we covered it but I
didn't announce it so but that's what
I'm saying I didn't get to announce I
did do pay-per-views but my firefights
at ESPN were great but they were you
know not as down in the level of
that but when I got to cover with a
Sports Center with you well that was the
height you just mentioned a highlight of
my career you say that no that's it
in fact I was thinking of retiring the
moment we finished that I said there's
nowhere else for me to go but getting
that getting this Showtime and the the
level of production the level of fights
that we did very extraordinary and we've
had great great fights over the last 15
years and it what's your highlight but
you know probably the best fight I ever
announced was the Diego Corrales Jose
Luis Castillo fight in 2005 it was
probably the best lightweight
championship fight that's ever been held
and it was one of the great fights and
of course I did Hagler Hearn so for me
to say that was one of the best fights
I've done it was it was like Hagler
Hearns times three cause it went nine
and a half rounds mmm and obviously
Mayweather Pacquiao would that be the
biggest marquee yes and then yeah that
one and McGregor Mayweather for whatever
it's worth I was here with you for that
that was in terms of sheer event that
was that was way up there man we had
Larry Merchant on here and he wanted no
part of discussed and then obviously I
understand there's you know Hatfields
and McCoys and turn yeah but out so many
of the purists just right oh god that
just I understand that I get that and I
and and you know it's it was an event
but yeah the whole Mayweather run we did
six of his fights and chronicled the
last part of his career in terms of
sheer events his fight with Canelo which
was an amazing event those were all
larger-than-life events and and those
are pretty extraordinary but the part
that is even better to me is the
consistent month by month really good
fights that we've had and especially in
the last 18 months we've had a great run
and now again 10:00 p.m. Eastern and
10:00 Pacific here on Saturday at
Staples Center the latest Showtime
championship boxing with you and I
totally understand that Holyfield more
to Gail me you and John Saracino of USA
Today at the time just it doesn't it
doesn't rank up there I agree it doesn't
rank up with the fights that you've
called al I understand that but and the
fact that I got to work with you has
always been a treasure we had a lot of
fun
we really did I remember that with
seriously I'll talk inside remember that
weekend we had a great time you did you
were so excited to come and do that that
that enthusiasm made me feel great
because I I just loved it Nancy I worked
with a lot of people when I did the
SportsCenter side of it you know you
Bob Lee I could name so many Charlie so
many people that I loved working with
and it was and I loved channeling their
enthusiasm for being there doing a
boxing man well your sweetness and being
out because I didn't really know very
much and you made me feel right at home
II when John did for sure but I was when
I first got there I was legitimately
upset you know why I was legitimate why
so because ESPN just at that very moment
lifted its requirement that everyone had
to wear a tux right I remember that and
I'm like I want to wear tuxedo and again
the fact that here comes this Schmo from
from SportsCenter bitching about not let
it touch a box like a dumb and Dumberer
bloomer bond situation that would have
been perfect wouldn't you have wanted to
do something like that Chris I mean of
course I love dressing up yeah you're
just pissed because there's breaking
Patriots news it is good to see you al
Bernstein check out again the latest
Showtime boxing championship boxing Leo
Santa Cruz and Abner Morris for the WBA
featherweight world championship that's
on Showtime 10:00 p.m. Eastern on
Saturday night the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience